and
[Music]
being an artist is my soul
is my life
[Music]
the town without art without customs without
flowers like
without identity without document don't
go much until 33 churches had a
time of color was in a
strategic place of  the fruits for Cusco
for Huancayo and for Lima
the concern was that they did not accept the
religion so the Spaniards
thought that we make altars but fused to
the animals
[Music]
yes yes
i
and it
was a look if you venerate this to your
animal and you must  play will take care of
them mothers then but insist they are
generating san juan santa inés tang lucas
and
[Music]
e
the Spanish have seen that it was difficult
to build a church in a short time they
have not seen it again  adapt it to bring a
small drawer but with an image in the
shape of a church
and that has been the prototype for
the altarpiece to be born
[Music]
there is actually a little pride in having been
born on this earth with all the
cultural wealth
ural well it's also sad that there are
some traditions, some cultures
like they are being lost
[Music]
calm down
before there was a purely
religious altarpiece to say the births the
passages of Holy Week
[Music]
oh
what we are focused on  as
producers it is not what is perceived to those
who have listened to
[Music]
and
oh
well
[Music]
like this
yes
[Music] when
we were very young we lived here
with my brother my parents because they were
artisans they traveled they sold
and  I am not always trying to emerge and
to move forward
I remember from a very young age that the people's war will
not be inroads because in
our
midst sometimes when one is a child because if
something happens I don't know what it will be in reality it was a
lack of knowledge
[Music]
later we started  to find out
what it could be, it has been a
strong revolution here listen
[Music]
quite difficult it does not escape me that we
did not have the money to
escape as well  Well,
I started this list when I saw my
brother on a mission and in 84
my brother practically disappeared
and my teaching practically stopped and
no
[Music]
when I make figures I feel it's like
my own creations I feel
perhaps free
from all the  but a thought of a
load no
[Music]
you have to question
yourself first and then consider yourself towards your community
because in order to recover things from
the Andean world you have to live it
[Music]
each person who has been
living there is having a little more  of
self-respect and respect for his own
land his own and Kantian
and
i
yes
[Music]
and
i
[Music]
and
well
[Music]